[Musique]
l injection et depuis le 31 mai possible
dès 18 ans et son co morbidités la
campagne de vaccination contre la copie
19 s'est élargi objectif du gouvernement
à atteindre les 30 millions de primo
vacciner enjoindre sensibiliser au
respect de l'environnement naturel
aventure c'est le rallye 100% féminin en
voiture électrique pour conduire de
façon économe trek et orientations le
départ a été donné devant la mairie de
versailles le 30 mai
sensibiliser jusque dans les foyers la
ville de ben a conçu des sacs à pain
avec numéros d'urgence et violente
omettre les deux boulangeries de la
ville vont distribuer dix mille sacs à
leurs clients un mois après le lancement
un premier bilan sur l'utilisation des
trottinettes électriques à saint quentin
en yvelines près de 2000 pas ses
abonnements ont été achetés 6000 trajets
ont été réalisés deux jours déco
festival les élèves du lycée 17 mar à
maurepas ont été sensibilisés à divers
pollution entre friterie gratuite et
expositions choc
[Musique]
comment